welcome everyone to the real world data
integration patterns on Google Cloud
my name is nothing more key and I'm a
product manager at Intel analytics firm
so before we get started on the patterns
of data integration in Google cloud
let's look at the what the traditional
view of data education is this
traditional view of EDA innovation
theory indication is such a prevalent
capability that exists across a wide
variety of industries and it's used
horizontally in various different
applications from a better perspective
what million equation provides is a
one-stop shop for handling a batch data
I know it does provide as the world was
patched originally so it does provide a
robust batch handling of the data it has
a hardened orchestration capabilities
and the most important of all it has
wide variety of connectors whether you
are connecting it to you know Tyler's
mainframes whether you are connecting
talking to databases or warehouses by a
variety of connector exists not only in
terms of social systems they can connect
to but also various different formats
that can be you know processed using
these tools so the best thing about a
delay integration solution the utility
of the tool that provides it is the the
user friendly environment all of the
data integration tools provide you a
user interface the visual development
and demand for creating these pipelines
you can think about every single any
tool that you take from the data
integration perspective has that studio
which can be used for building ETL
pipelines and they're easy you can drag
and drop you can draw different
components in there and figure them and
there you go you have a much easier way
of moving data around and the one thing
that is very clear after looking at you
know being in this industry for quite
some time now is they are optimized what
I find is they're more optimized for
unfeminine and on-time environment it's
very like from a fixed processing
capability
like the amount of optimization that
goes in essentially an amount of data
that you can handle it's all like you
know it's very much controlled and
limited in some sense right but what
what is happening is in the cloud right
education still plays a very vital role
there are a lot of benefits that data
integration provides and then the thing
is it enables business to have various
different you know enable various
different aspects of the business one
thing I would like to talk about this
faster in time to insights having a much
easier way of specifying how your
transformation is providing a visual
environment to feedback where you don't
have to write a lot of code and then
manage it and then just you know we've
all but over a period of time but having
a standardized way of doing that is
extremely important and this allows us
this allows customers to have faster
time to insights now because it's a
standardized way of specifying
transformations in a visual environment
for providing all of the transformations
as to change things that are require for
movement of the data and and
operationally it provides a standard way
for monitoring these things it provides
lower TC and because of its simplicity
you don't have to be an expert you don't
have to understand infrastructure to
actually go ahead and are you business
to you it then is thus provides wider
access ability now a lot of business
analysts or data analyst can actually
use this tool to apply and new
transformations and move the data around
in their organization for their business
reporting or analytics needs because of
the ability to again you know the
simplicity that it provides I would
rather say simplicity that it provides
and also the consistency and anakata is
that it provides in terms of how we are
actually move data around how you do
data manipulation standardization and
cleansing it provides operational
efficiency right so and the best part of
any data integration solution is while
you are in at Point a you are in
development environment you're
developing the pipeline or designing the
pipeline immediately you can take what
you have plated and translate that
operationally being able to run that in
a production environment right so this
and being able to monitor that in a
consistent way helps the DevOps team
DevOps teams have to just know once what
they need to do and they're able to take
all of that the learnings from one cell
pipeline and apply the same thing to
other pipelines that get developed as
part of this now because an integration
to talks to a lot of systems right
systems of sources or formats it doesn't
matter they are able to capture a lot of
material and that metadata whether it is
technical business and operational
metadata is extremely important and if
it provides a lot of insight into the
data and these are some of the benefits
that you know data integration basically
enable enables right so this is without
these it becomes very hard when you are
actually looking to move my great and
you know evolve the data strategy that
you have the Technion organization but
none of these when you look at the
traditional unit and the benefits that
these these tools provide with the new
era cloud era you are actually seeing a
lot more challenges in the current world
you are seeing a lot more challenges and
these challenges can be classified into
three parts one is the proving data
assets you're all of there is more data
everywhere you're not able to actually
get handle on all of the data if you are
giving access to that data you just
don't know how we can bring them all
together to follow our analytics are for
your business reporting it's very hard
you would have to do an ad hoc one time
you know
point-to-point integrations whether
you're doing it manually do it yourself
it doesn't matter really the whole idea
here is it takes a lot of effort to do
that and as the data assets grow
exponentially it makes it extremely
difficult to bring data from from
various different you know silos or
environments into one single place
that's a huge challenge right now now
adding to that challenge is the
city of Denver omelets now we are
talking about you know before we used to
talk about on everything being on trend
behind the firewall life was good but
now it's not the case you have content
you have data centers then you have
private cloud then you have public
clouds now the public clouds coming in
not everything can move into public art
you have hybrid and people also adopt
multiple clouds so there's some delay
and cloud a some data in cloud B so your
data is did a success rate across now
that the complexity is how do you manage
data that spread across various
different environments it's extremely
you use five different tools you choose
to basically you know do it all by
yourself individually for each of these
environments it's just it's just
incomprehensible for you basically take
all of these things and bring them
together seamlessly right so this is
essentially leaving the lot more
problems and challenges from data
indication perspective and these are
some of the things that you know
traditionally during immigration proofs
have to solve for now the last one is we
because there is so much data that is
being ingested there's a lot more
material that's being aggregated all of
the metadata that is being advocated is
passive right now there is no
intelligence built on that metadata to
actually leverage that metadata to make
better decisions of you know building
smarter pipeline so essentially figuring
out how to execute you know in a much
better way all these type of things are
something that the traditional view
bases now now that we have looked at
what a traditional view is what are the
benefits of having a better integration
solution and when you look at a look at
the challenges that it presents what you
have an R star data integration solution
should look like it's very simple I have
simplified this picture too there are so
many different aspects of it but I have
tried simplifying and try to focus on
core components that need to be existing
in a peer education solution for future
so this is where we are headed towards
first of all any data migration
solutions should basically support
different environments that can run on
whether it's hybrid multi-cloud GCP it
doesn't matter you should be able to
support
seamlessly running on all these
environments second it should have
seamless ability for aggregating
metadata from various different sources
right so on all the sources that it
interacts with it has to aggregate all
of that metadata without its it should
be hassle-free it should not be like
someone has to spend a huge amount of
time to bring that data once the
metadata comes in the tira have metadata
has to be activated when you say
activating that metadata means we are
essentially gathering insights from that
metadata understanding how different
entities and their semantics and the
relationships takes is understand more
in depth about the characteristics of
the data once you know more about it
leverage it an active activated metadata
in terms of automating indications right
so you will then have recommendations
probably you will make changes to it in
terms of assisting in the development of
the the pipelines that you are doing
building actually all those type of
things become extremely important and
the one thing that we would always think
about when you want from an OnStar
perspective for Atia integration
solution is the ability to orchestrate
so our distribution is a complex piece
and when you think about orchestration
it's not just about orchestration of
pipelines so there are several different
components that need to be orchestrated
that are that are really important and
that is something the orchestration
capability needs to be provided in
addition to that the the most important
and also one of the important things
from a perspective of manageability is
data operations having the ability to
manage the pipeline's understanding the
SLA is ability to monitor them
constantly it's extremely poor so when
you think about it from all of these
capabilities that needs to be existing
in you know in our ideal terrain
integration solution you can think about
this tweaking being a more integrated
platform right it's comprehensive set of
capabilities whether you are actually
moving during 12 banks we
I'm assuming it doesn't matter how it
has to provide like you know deep
transfer spot transformation
capabilities it should support giving
data whether it like you know in
real-time replication or pacification or
it's enough like it it's basically
snapshot third but ability to do that in
chance this will all be supported right
and and most importantly a data
integration solution should provide
ability to improve the quality of the
data as you basically integrate go to
the integration process it should not be
that the integration process actually
you know and like you know reduces the
quality of the data it should actually
make it easy for improving the quality
of the data and that's something that we
believe are not star a hypothetical data
integration solution should be providing
right so so now that we have looked at
what are the key things that we need to
be existing solution let's compare that
with what do we have in GCC and you know
we have all of the ingredients there are
a lot of missing pieces too and we will
talk about what we have today and where
we want to see in the future the data
indication to be wrong so what do we
have right we have you know five or six
components that are already available
let's let's go through them first
which one is data catalog and you know
it's basically a single catalog for
storing all of the metadata then you
have composer which provides a workflow
management you have fusion which is the
integration solution or service then you
have data flow and reprocessing which
are essentially transformational engines
that based that that you know the radius
for processing your gear and then you
have data pair which is white label
factor which provides the ranking
capability so these are all like you
know six components six services that
you know integral part of an integration
solution so we'll look at some of the
capabilities that exist across all of
these that will enable us to have a
better indication from the kind of a
good indication solution on GCP so
drive people to understand what are the
different capabilities that we have here
so first thank you in order to have
during irrigation for optimize analytics
you need to be able to have faster time
to inserts and what does that mean
ability to support rod set of connectors
and formats I should be able to extract
data from databases SAS sources cloud
you know even mainframes like various
different components we should be able
to pull that data and not only that why
we are able to connect to various
different source systems you should be
also be able to support various
different form so you should have Jason
CSV XML it's all seven those kind of
things just the next thing is for data
integration solution right so we do have
Intel fusion the ability to have a code
free environment right and with code so
you can write code or if you don't need
to write code right so you can do the
transformations and prepare all your
data without having to write any code
you can just now go just with your mouse
you'll be able to you know bring data
from various different sources transform
and without having to absolutely write
anything
now once you write this code the thing
is you need to have the ability to
attest it while you're doing functional
Paris to your trying to understand
whether the logic that you have build is
actually working as expected
ability to do to push the system into a
preview stage where you can look at any
processed parts of the data to get a
better understanding of the the
functionality with r88 has to as per
your requirements of not it's critically
important functional test capability is
being provided as part of it right so
operationally
I mean you from a CI CD perspective you
should be still able to support thinking
the pipeline's that you have build and
be able to take all of that stuff and
push it into into a CI see the
environments of that you can automate
the test as possible so these black D
data from various different sources
extremely important so we diffusion as
an example bill allows you to bring data
from various different sources whether
you are bringing data from a DBMS
warehouses SAS sources cloud named
French it doesn't matter
please 200 plus connectors that are that
exists right now indeed a fusion that
allows you to think this time now all of
this figure can be processed you know
using me as different systems data
fusion can basically allow you to do
that but you can also use data prop you
can also use bigquery you can also use
data flow right so data fusion right now
when you think about it from a
processing perspective actually runs
onto a problem actually so it basically
uses data processor processing engine or
the transformation engine but in the
future it will also use bigquery and and
data flow for doing all of these stuff
right but as part of the integration
solution you have the ability to ingest
data from all of these sources bringing
that into GCP seamlessly so in order to
accelerate transformations for analytics
one of the important things is you know
the data delivery modes can be delivered
of the data in bulk batch and streaming
fashion yes of course we can do that so
let's talk about diffusion the diffusion
basically allows you to do you know
provides the delivery modes or like in
in bulk and packs come also streaming
most of these actually ran on take
appropriate in fact it's like spot if it
is real-time it's using spark streaming
in the additional thing in addition to
that you can of course use the approach
and data provides a similar capabilities
but you will just not have that the top
level environment which makes it easy
for defining all these transformations
but he comes for strikes popcorn into
the top to be able to do that the same
thing exists from a data flow
perspective data flow has templates if
you want to use you know as a gentleman
to define these things but you can also
use data flow wave one with its own API
is to be able to apply all of these
transformations as part of it now the
interesting part of this is the refuge
data flow is actually really good about
streaming so it provides amazing
streaming capabilities to be able to
pull all of the data in a streaming
fashion do analysis on and being able to
write
they're into bigquery or any other
static systems I see now data fusion is
the only component that provides the
visual environment for you know
composing the pipelines it basically
provides an easy-to-use interface which
allows you to cleanse transform you know
standardize canonicalize do a CDS
aggregate join group by such
transformations can be easily composed
within data fusion now across all of the
tools services that I talked about not
sorry - so this is that I talked about
there is the ability for gathering
operational insights based on the
pipeline's that you run there are like a
lot of different metrics that were
gathered at various different stages
data fusion to provide that data flow
also provides that so there is an
operational dashboard that can be looked
at in order to understand the
performance of the pipeline and tune
them and find in the processing right so
some of these things are available as
part of it out of the box so while you
know the region can be used from an
integration perspective all of the
processing still happens on aircraft
potato power and data fuel flow can be
used independently for doing building
some of these capabilities if you would
like to have the non-visual environment
right so the transformation engine of
the diffusion but they can be used
independently for even doing the same
tasks so the quest mail thing the one
point that I want to make here is we
have a capability right now proton data
fusion pipelines between two data prop
the capability for running it on data
flow doesn't exist so if you are
interested and if you would like to see
data flow integration happening with
data fusion
please do send us and let's talk and let
us talk further about the use case that
we have and how we can essentially help
you would love to get a lot more free
plaque on this so please do let us know
as soon as you can so and draw
orchestration perspective of course
composer is the best and it allows you
to you know castrate not only just data
fusion pipelines but you cannot stretch
bands and various different things right
so from
one thing to note is there's a better
integration between proposer and M data
fluoroacetate effusion right now so
proposal workflows have actions now that
will allow you to deploy to the
start-stop those kind of things do the
lifecycle management of the pipeline's
for a patient so let's talk about
Medicare metadata right so like I talked
about it before metadata plays a very
vital role in the next generation data
integration solution right now the
difference between what exists today and
what what what we need to food shoot for
tomorrow is the activating the metadata
that we have exist currently existing
there's a lot of metadata that's
collected it's just sitting there people
can look carry they can they get a feel
good about that they have metadata but
there is nothing else more than that
that we are actually doing with that
metadata so the next generation data
integration solution should be taking
all of the metadata and looking at it
from the different lens and using that
information for building better
integration solutions right so the first
thing the first step for doing all of
that is the ability to capture all of
that metadata automatically and this is
where technical business and operational
method and business metadata by will be
a little bit difficult because business
metadata requires you to you know have a
good understanding of the business but
at least technical and operational
metadata can be automatically captured
as part of it now once you have captured
that ability to take an end-to-end view
of that negative end of the day right so
looking at the metadata you are able to
construct an end-to-end view of it
you are you are able to understand the
tira model you are able the data and get
a better understanding of that data all
that plays a very vital role in
establishing various different
relationship that can exist between
native assets right so this is something
that is important and that needs to be
captured and we do that today so as part
of diffusion we automatically build a
pipeline all metadata gets captured
automatically and you essentially run a
query in big query that metadata gets
captured into data catalog seamlessly
the third part of this is I don't you
know
there will be multiple data catalogues I
don't think we can ever say there will
be one single catalog that everyone
think I would love to have that vision
and I know whoever wants that central
data catalog will actually own the data
actors but the biggest benefit that the
customers will have that is having a
centralized data catalog is the ability
to optimize their processing for cost
for execution for SL A's you know before
even identifying the best tool or best
workload and basically a best tool for
that work right so having that ability
is important so now the thing is in
order to support that kind of vision you
need to have the ability to exchange
data between catalogs so there needs to
be standard you know formats of exchange
right or we need to expose ApS and we do
take a developer's the city of catalog
also exposes that method it out for it
we consume but there is but it does have
an API which can use but it's not very
comprehensive here from a data capital
Rd refusal perspective so for people who
don't know what data catalog is just
just to give recap on that data catalog
is a catalog solution it's a metadata
system which allows you to discover
manage and understand your data asset
right so it's it's basically provides
the ability to index all of the metadata
that is aggregated and provides a
discoverability
I like search capability but you can
search it based on the label so you can
search it based on name description it
also includes a free text search as part
of it so it also is the foundational
layer for actually it's a foundational
layer for comments it's integrated with
DLP and it's integrated with I am and
for people who know DLP is the data loss
prevention which allows you to tag
sensitive data and you can you all that
sensitive data that gets tagged get
surfaced up in their catalog which can
be then you know a proper action can be
associated with it once that particular
sensitive data has been identified from
yes there is no discussion that ever
happens about metadata which does not
involve data lineage and data lineage is
a critical aspect of data integration
solution and one of the main reasons for
that is people our customers would like
to understand the flow of the data right
they would like to understand how the
data that is being prepared for business
was generated because if the business
decisions are based on the data of final
analytics data that was created they
would like to understand how that data
was generated due for auditing purposes
from compliance purposes this is this is
an essential and a critical component
that any data integration solution
should be able to support now what does
being their only means provide it
provides a granular visibility into the
flow of the data when you look at this
particular picture here if you see there
are a lot of different fine-grained
details that are being provided so
individual field level the data is being
captured when you look at like an
individual field you have to understand
where it came from you also have to
understand where it is going to use
right so like what is the downstream
processing that it actually will be
doing now when you think about it from
that perspective this also allows you to
have more of an operational view right
so you are able to look at it and say
you know this particular data set was
created from three these three different
data sets and these are the few things
that were you know transformed in order
to create this individual fields that
exist in the target data set right and
that is something that has to be you
know captured and seamlessly without any
human intervention it has to be
catalogued they have to be represented
as track right and then visualized and
this is something that is being provided
out-of-the-box as part of the data
creation so Lily it also allows you to
have things like a root cause analysis
impact analysis problems all these kind
of things comes out-of-the-box from that
perspective and as part of the DNA
creation solution like particularly and
I have seen customers says that and I
mean every time it can be a separate
solution but
it doesn't matter because the only way
why you generally see that image is
asked from an intubation perspective is
because integration solutions allow you
to capture the transformations in a
standard form that you are combining two
columns or creating ten columns or in a
filtering data these standard operations
essentially have to be captured in a
standard array and then they can be
associated with every individual field
that exists as part of the integration
process and then be able to you know
visualize them seamlessly as part of it
right so you get a full depth you cannot
just take any data write it in a C code
and then say oh so with the linear it
doesn't come for free there it needs to
be then something API is that a provider
that basically have to be used for
capturing the metadata of the operations
that the code so if you think of it this
way you would have to write the
documentation for the operations that
you are doing and then you have to do
the operations that's exactly what needs
to be happening if you're not using and
kind of like an integration solution or
a structure in your on and sequel is a
very structured environment so that's
fine but being able to do it in an ad
hoc environment is extremely complex for
you okay next next thing that is
important is opens openness or ability
to share the minions like I said catalog
to catalog exchanges are going to become
more calm that I don't believe I will
have one catalog that basically you know
collects everything which is totally
possible in one environment but you know
different choices different customer
requirements you might end up in a
situation where you have to share so
like you know a catalog you can use ap I
used to do that but a diffusion you can
celebrity use ap has to do that and
their fusion ApS allows you to extract
instrument data consistency very
important right you have to be confident
in the decisions that you are making for
your business on the based on the data
that you have integrated right so the
first thing you have to ensure is when
someone builds data quality rules or
someone doing a transformation we are
making it hard to make mistakes right so
you have to have ability to you know
with existing predefined directors and
things that exist it just makes it
extremely easy for defining them the
next is ability to profile data and and
you know identifying quality issues in
this region right now you have a
profiler that you can include in the
pipeline that allows you to extract a
lot of different meta data that exists
in MN ability to extract a lot of
you know metrics from the deal right so
eh and help identify you know the
various categorical data it has a lot of
different metrics quantitative data and
then boolean right to you you can
essentially look at different statistics
being generated for different categories
of data and then you can investigate
that to make better decisions based on
the statistics of the data right so you
can at least help identify the problems
with the veteran issues having dinner
drafts nothing is constant things keep
changing their assets evolve so things
gets added things get subtracted things
here like you know modified so ability
to you know first detect those changes
that happened in the system next ability
to take actions on them is critically
important right the data fusion we do
provide some of the capabilities in
handling data rates we are able to
identify them and we can take certain
actions either you can drop them or
essentially you can you know filter them
off but the thing that we don't have
here test being able to talk and I
wouldn't say that yet but the ability to
apply the changes on the target is not
consistently available across different
components of it it always depends on
the target system to which this may be
applied so it is in case by case basis
at least from at eight-fifteen
perspective and when you're talking
important and data get a flow or they
prop you have pain to make that fire the
next piece is open habitat multi-cloud
around we believe in GCP that having the
ability to take an integration solution
and moving that into any environment
ships you know should give you more
power should give customers the more for
having that ability to do that you know
exists today
frankly look at it see a diffusion is
based on Syrah open source which came
from cask so that allows you to actually
run it on track you can run it on friend
you run it on another cloud when you
think about it from a conclusive
perspective it's based on a flow so you
can run air flow on time I'm not saying
that this is the best way of doing it
but by next next we will have more news
around what what we are doing there but
the whole idea here is you today have
the ability to come them in in these
environments right so you can deploy
them in a hybrid environment at the
coffee lounge and when you think about
it from a flow perspective which
provides streaming capabilities you have
a patchy beam as an alternative and open
source and you can use that in this is
one of the important aspects of an
integration solution Security's is is
the ability to store the keys in a
secure fashion because there are many
aspects of data integration that are
that have to be stored in a secure
manner whether it's passwords are tokens
all these cannot be in plain text field
in then within your pipeline right so
you would have to store them in kms and
when you run a job the people with the
right access will have the permissions
to extract those keys and be able to run
that job so all of the solutions
integrate with TMS the ability to mask
with a tenant is critically important
well this might be you know you might
think of we are not talking here about
masking redacting and encrypting all of
the data and all importance of the data
here having the ability to uniquely
identify a certain sensitive fields be
able to mask them attack them or encrypt
them is a creative ability to have an
any integration solution should be able
to provide that kind of capability now
for TCP we have one of the best
technologies that is available to DLP
that provides us ability to mask that
can encrypt
so data fusion is integrated with the
DLP a few configurations and off you go
you are able to encrypt all of the
or encrypted you can do the same thing
with data flow and as well as data craft
with a standards and compliance as they
are the most important thing for us data
protection is the most important thing
for TCP but we spend a huge amount of
time in ensuring that we are headed to
the industry standards for data
protection policies and compliant and be
compliant with it if our PCI DSS solve
these are some of the some of the things
from compliance perspective that we are
here and there's a long list of things
that I want that be basically M
compliant offer now when you look at its
our data protection perspective when you
want to you know ingesting it from our
current system you need to have the
ability to you need to have the ability
to have access to that data so in which
case you don't want to expose all of
your internal systems to the cloud you
want to have much more fine-grained you
know intrusive these type of things the
private IP be to support those kind of
capability very can expose within your
environment within your IP range you can
basically give access to that ability to
enter data at rest when you think about
it from that perspective we need to have
you know even if we use the customer
managed encryption scheme any of these
tools should basically as part of an
integration solution should provide you
the ability to pass on the information
or the encryption key that is being
provided to the underlying storage
system that the interior actually gets
told and it's encrypted using the key
that has been specified by the customer
right in addition to that the data
exfiltration process its protection
which is extremely important you want
certain regions are certain regions
within the big patient data that it
should recite so you can use with the
CSC control security parameters around
that that will allow you to protect the
region image that either should be
residing and all of these services that
I talked about a fusion therefore they
all provide that connectivity now
putting it all together here is the
interesting thing right like we talked
about various different services various
different capabilities that exist they
need to be all put together into a
single cams and this is where data
fusion actually
is going to take shape itself you will
have the ability where you will drill
all of the the capabilities that we
talked the power some take catalog data
flow such kind of things and push them
into into data fusion as at the face
part right well all the way you can use
all of these capabilities individually
but from a data integration solution we
are essentially bringing them all
together into this piece so we're all
things will be in debating right so when
you think about it some from just from a
future perspective you would have like
we are already looking at you know we
already run in on Peter craft we already
run on earmark
right so weíll also integrates with like
the query and data flow so the whole
idea here is depending on the pipeline
the characteristics of the pipeline and
the theta that is associated with the
pipeline you need to be able to click
pigeon or mentor which transformation
engine should be used for processing
back segment of the pipeline that's that
basically can be you know providing cost
optimization SLA optimization these are
the two things that would be exposed to
the user so that they can control it of
course as a user you would need to have
the ability to choose that you would
want to have this engine to be the
default and you want to run an entire
pipeline of this right so but having
that ability is extremely important so
that's one place where we basically
bring that all into this canvas the
second is like I talked about metadata
will play a very vital role and so we
will be debating looking at integrating
with data catalog because it becomes a
critical piece from an integration
solution perspective you need to bring
all of the metadata that exists there as
well as be able to exchange the metadata
that exists in the city of capital with
catalog so they will be working in
conjunction to essentially activate that
metadata so that we can do better
information provide like smart mapping
capabilities provide the ability to
recommendations for things that have to
be you know defined from a pipeline
perspective or transformation
perspective standardization perspective
so all that gets part together in a much
more coherent way as part of Alexia
so this is one thing that I wanted
and you know many customers have asked
about it and you might be already one
thing because we talked about it in the
previous next replicators it is
basically a CDC solution that will be
coming that basically we are working
towards as part of a diffusion right so
this is something will be available in
diffusion it's a new data fusion add-on
they have these introduced these
concepts of add-on which where it can
have a single data fusion instance and
add these on top of it to accelerate
your application of data from you know
at low latency in real time from
operational databases into Piqua so will
be only supporting target as a big query
for this year but in the future we'll be
changing that to include other targets
too as part of it so it's a log based
application so it will support different
sources and as we come closer we will be
we can talk further if there are certain
you know sources that you are interested
in please do come talk to us we'll be
more than happy to understand your use
case and prioritize that way so with
that I think we have toured a lot of
different aspects of data integration
and I think I would like to basically
leave you with where we are seeing in
the future and they are going to be
heading in the future when you combine
all of those different aspects that we
talked about for an ideal data
integration solution to itself this
picture looks you know complex but
actually is not when you think about
what is the most important thing tea
mistakes will always have the resources
that will be coming from various
different aspects of the organization
and various different systems that will
generate a lot of metadata there are
different metadata technical operational
business social quality like you know
there are a lot of different metadata
types that will be generated right now
all that metadata exists in systems it
exists in catalog regulate it exists in
the effusion catalog but all of that
metadata is you know providing you know
different definition for the print is
this mag meaningful and they're
providing relationships the definitely
des assets all of that is passive right
now so you can think that enter it into
an active metadata view whether you
activate that a metadata basically use
you
use a IML method to generate your
insights
I'm abstracting me I'm not trying to get
deeper into this but you will be able to
extract a lot of information from that
metadata which we have actually seen it
it brings in a huge amount of
information from it like if you look at
our operational metadata you can
essentially look at different ways of
optimizing your pipelines you look at
the utilization you look at like
annotative quality you get a lot of
different aspects that basically are
metadata all this can then be pushed in
from a smart education perspective it
will be again which will be enriched
with automated with active metadata
right like so all that stuff gets
combined together in such a way like I
talked about an adaptive execution that
plays a very vital role in the next
generation which is not to be
incapacitated Fusion is ability to run
across these engines right so as a
customer I mean you should not be
worrying about where actually your
pipeline runs of course you would need
to have controls in SLA and cost would
rest all should be taken care of
automatically whether you run it on
train with Eliminator cloud whether it
where you run it it shouldn't matter
that's point a point B the parts of the
Bible I should be able to select the
best engine that it should be running on
right so all that combined together
provides an active adaptive education
environment now double that we have to
have the best orchestration capability
that allows not only just the day agent
my branch but also going wide across the
pool for supporting the elder indirectly
integration means in addition to that I
do like data operations security
compliance there's a pretty much stable
States and the solutions are now should
basically provide staff providing
industry vertical incision for retail
finance for telcos for different
industries we should be able to have you
know three build solutions that
basically come out of the box for
customers to use right so this is the
view of the future of how the data
intubation could evolve into and this is
how the diffusion would evolve into
that's all if you guys have any
questions and be more than happy to take
them thank you for your time